New tonight, a lawyer for
Jean Carroll
saying the writer may sue Trump again
for comments
he made during last night's
CNN town hall,
mocking her claim that he raped her
in a Manhattan Department
store in the mid 1990s.
I never met this woman.
I never saw this woman, this woman said.
I met her
at the front door of Bergdorf Goodman,
which I rarely go into, other
than for a couple of charities.
This is a fake story, made up story
attorney for Carroll
telling The New York Times.
Everything's on the table, obviously,
and we have to give serious consideration
to suing Trump again.
It comes as Trump
officially filed his appeal
and the $5 million jury decision
that found that he sexually abused
and defamed Carroll.
OUTFRONT now, Ryan Goodman, co
editor in chief of Just Security.
Also former
special counsel
of the Defense Department.
So, Ryan, let's start there.
These these comments
we've just played from Trump,
they match almost identically
with his social media posts
on October 2022, almost identically.
But that is very significant
because that post is a post
that the jury found to be defamatory
in this case. Quote, I don't know.
This woman have no idea who she is.
She completely made up a story.
So do you think she could win
another defamation case?
Absolutely.
Because it is a kind of a replica
of what he said before.
A jury has already found
unanimously that that was defamatory.
And, in fact,
she could actually walk into the court
and say
part of this has already been decided
between these two parties.
There's already
a unanimous verdict
that I was telling the truth
about the sexual assault.
And what he did
was maliciously defaming me.
And here he has done it again. Right.
So she could absolutely do it now.
I guess the big question is, will she
I mean, she already has a victory.
She's got $5 million.
You know, it's
a very personal choice
as to whether or not
she wants to do it
and put herself through another trial.
But she might be able
to convince the judge that,
as I mentioned, in a certain sense,
some of these issues
have already been decided.
So she does not have to
go through the rigor again
of going through what happened to her
that will already be established.
And then she can
just go to the question of defamation,
not to the question of whether or not
there was a sexual assault.
Okay. So take that part away.
All right.
Which could be very significant.
Now, you're
pointing to a few other comments
last night
that could impact the two DOJ
criminal cases
in which we are still awaiting
potential indictment from the DOJ.
So let's start with January six.
Caitlin asked Trump about the danger
that was posed to his
then Vice President, Mike Pence.
Let me play that exchange.
The person who was at the
Capitol that day, as you know,
was your vice president, Mike Pence,
who says that you endangered his life
on that day.
I don't think he was in any danger.
Mr.
President,
do you feel that you owe him an apology?
No, because he did something wrong.
He should have put the votes
back to the state legislatures.
And I think
we would have had a different outcome
You find that incriminating.
Explain.
It's very similar to the testimony
that was given
to the January six committee
where he says
Pence deserved it in the sense
that he was put in danger.
And then the answer is no.
But he is responsible
for having put himself in danger by not
decertifying or trying to interfere
with the certification of the election.
He's seeing it similarly.
And also
his lawyer says that to Pence's
lawyer in the midst of the attack,
Eastman says to Greg Jacob,
No you all are responsible for this,
because if your boss, Pence,
had acted differently,
there wouldn't be this violence
that's very incriminating.
And it also goes with him
suggesting that he would pardon
some of these people,
even up to the Proud Boys.
It's an endorsement of the violence
in a certain sense.
And I think that would be really
important evidence
that, in fact, that the DOJ would use
before a jury
if they did bring it to that.
All right. So that is significant.
There's also the Mar a Lago
classified documents case
that you think is front and center here.
Let me play the exchange
over the classified documents
Did you ever show those
classified documents to anyone?
Not really.
I would have the right to.
By the way, they were demystified after.
Not that I can think of.
Let me just tell you,
I have the absolute
right to do whatever I want with them.
Not really.
And not that I can think of.
So that's hedging on this
very important question.
Did you share it with anybody else?
If he shared that those documents
with anybody else?
It puts the case
in a very different category
under the Espionage Act
and it ratchets up the likelihood
that he'll be indicted,
because that's a very different
kind of a case
if you share it with other people.
The fact that he's hedging like that,
I'm sure
everybody inside of Jake Smith's,
the special counsel's
office, their ears perked up
because he's not denying
that he did that.
It sounds like there's
something really there.
Plus, he's
also saying that he was aware
that the documents were removed
from the White House.
That's another piece
that he said last night.
That is really important to the case.
All right.
Well, of course,
as we await
those those possible indictments,
whether there would be one
in January six as well,
Mar a Lago,
whether they come together or not.
We await.
All right, Ryan, thank you very much.
And I want to go now
to a Republican congressman
from New York, Mike Lawler.
He has said the GOP needs
to move on from Trump.
And Congressman, I appreciate your time.
So, you know,
you heard Ryan there explaining why
Trump may have put himself
in even more legal jeopardy
with those comments
that we were just playing
about the classified documents
case about Pence and January six.
But of course, the other part of this
is that the people in the room
were applauding Trump as he said this.
What's your feeling about that?
Does it make
you want to move on from Trump even more?
Well, I can't speak to the CNN town hall
or how,
you know, the audience was selected
or the topics discussed.
I mean, that's something
obviously you guys
can speak to better than I.
But, you know,
look, I've said repeatedly that
you know,
I think the party needs to move in
in a new direction that I think
whoever the nominee is needs
to be focused on the future.
And the challenges
facing the American people right now
in Congress,
we're
focused on the debt ceiling
and the migrant crisis
impacting our nation.
And, you know,
when I met with the president
yesterday in my district,
that is what I talked about.
That was my focus on the issues
that we're dealing with.
And so,
you know,
I'm not interested in relitigating 2020.
I've said repeatedly, Joe Biden
won the election.
It's time to move on from that.
So so and I'm going to ask you
both about debt and immigration.
But but first,
I do want to ask you one other thing,
because what matters here
at this moment in time,
whatever the predicate is,
is what other Republicans
are going to do.
You know, you're talking about yourself,
but there are Republicans
who have been strong
supporters of Trump in the past
who are breaking with him
over some of his remarks last night.
And I wanted to play two of them.
They may surprise you.
Senator Hawley is one of them.
Senator Tillis is another one.
They're weighing in
on the fact
that Trump promised
yet again pardons for January 6th riders.
Here they are
Anybody who
crossed in to the
end of the Capitol,
under the circumstances
that I witnessed firsthand,
it's hard for me to have a positive
predisposition towards them.
But just generally, I disagree.
But if you're asking me, do
I think you should
pardon people who engage in, like,
rioting behavior? No, I don't.
And
now of course,
Senator Holly, as you're well aware,
Congressman voted to overturn
the election.
He had that famous,
you know,
fist bump to the pro-Trump
crowd on January six
before it stormed the Capitol.
But neither of those senators
actually went so far
as to say they would not support Trump
if it is a nominee.
They're not saying, let's move it.
They're not saying what you're saying.
Right. Loudly and clearly.
So what do you read into this?
Do you think this is the beginning
of real cracks in Trump's
core support or not?
Well, look, I can't speak to others
and what they think
or how they're going
to act during this primary process.
What I can say
is this with respect to January six,
I was the first state legislator
in New York to condemn it.
I don't care, frankly, who it is.
Anybody who stormed the Capitol
should be held responsible
for their own conduct,
just like anybody
who stormed
the federal courthouse in Oregon
or anybody
who burned a police
precinct to the ground.
When you commit acts of violence,
you should be held liable.
Period.
And as far as I'm concerned, you know,
that's the bottom line on this.